is 32 gigabytes really worth the extra
400 we will find out because i have the
same exact macbooks in front of me other
than one being a 16 gigabyte model and
the other being a 32 gig model let's
start out by opening up five safari tabs
let's go ahead and open up lightroom
classic let's hit that export look how
much memory pressure we have and even
though we did have to write to the ssd
on the 16 gig model you see the
performance hit is almost non-existent i
went ahead and i opened 10 tabs in
chrome the difference is only three
seconds now and now let's export this
five minute project the difference was
only six seconds and now let's open up
xcode that's not that much time that is
19 faster this is a five minute project
and i'm going out to h.265 it beat out
the 16 gig model by one second i gotta
be honest with you guys i thought there
was gonna be a bigger difference than
this it would just be worth getting a 16
gig and spending that extra money on
more ssd space